a sunny day in occupied East Jerusalem
but the closest Hana dehalavani can get
to it is by standing behind this window
her home has become her prison
she's under house arrest because Israeli
authorities claim she protested Israeli
occupation forces storming Al-Aqsa
mosque
I was born in Jerusalem my house is near
the Alexa mosque I can hear the call to
prayer coming from us visitors to Alexa
mosque park in front of my house but I
can't join them it's Ramadan and now Eid
is approaching my children are growing
but I can't be with them to enjoy these
spiritual moments
Israeli occupation forces issue orders
prohibiting Palestinians from entering
Al-Aqsa mosque without a court decision
on what they say are security grounds
the bands can be relieved and extended
indefinitely
according to the Community Action Center
in Jerusalem's Old City approximately
500 Palestinians who live in the
occupied east of the city are currently
barred from practice in their faith in
Al-Aqsa of course it's illegal
international law all these types of
collective punishment and deprivation of
freedom and arbitrary measures
are contrary to international human
rights law but also International
humanitarian law which regulates
situations of occupation Israeli forces
put firm security measures around the
Al-Aqsa compound
in these last days of Ramadan all
non-muslims are bad access many
Palestinians here are under constant
surveillance
they say occupation forces not only
restrict access to place of worship but
also deliberately undermine the sense of
normalcy by imposing Extreme Measures
when ultranationalist Israelis make
inclusions into Al-Aqsa most compound
they're protected by Israeli occupation
forces who sometimes Force Palestinian
worshipers out of the mosque those who
do not live are often beaten and
arrested to minimize such resistance
Israeli occupation forces issue ban
orders denying Palestinians the right to
visit Al-Aqsa mosque Islam's third
holiest side
occupied East Jerusalem